c'est un objectif prioritaire pour la
Russie c'est vérodonezk ville de l'est
de l'Ukraine est l'un des nombreux
fronts ou l'armée russe et ses alliés
livre de violents combats face aux
Ukrainiens 80% de la ville et désormais
aux mains des troupes russes et prorus
selon les autorités locales dans le
donbasse elles avancent lentement mais
sûrement malgré tout le président
ukrainien vole aux dimensellinski tente
de faire bonne figure la situation dans
le don-basse n'a pas changé de manière
significative nous avons quelques succès
dans les batailles pour CV redonnette
mais il est un peu tôt pour tirer des
conclusions c'est la zone la plus
difficile pour nous en ce moment comme
dans les villes les localités voisines
l'ici change barmut et d'autres
les renseignements britanniques estiment
que la province de luansk est contrôlée
à 90% par les troupes fidèles à Moscou
comme ici à Pau pacna où elle distribue
de la duanitaire devant les caméras
depuis la chute de Mario Paul le 21 mai
dernier Moscou contrôle désormais tout
un corridor stratégique c'est en de la
Crimée à la frontière avec la Russie
l'état-major russe affirme avoir réduit
les arrivées de combattants étrangères
en Ukraine grâce à de nombreuses frappes
dans l'ouest du pays
de mercenaires étrangers en Ukraine
voulant prendre part aux hostilités
contre l'armée russe c'est pour ainsi
dire tari selon les données dont nous
disposons le nombre total a quasiment
été divisé par deux passant de 6600 à
selon l'OTAN la Russie a mis en place
une guerre d'usure en Ukraine qui semble
porter ses fruits pour inverser la
tendance les Ukrainiens comptent sur la
livraison des nouvelles armes
américaines promises par Joe Biden